بالانتقال الى تونس ففي خضني حمله
اعتقالات واسعه تطالب رموز المعارضه ينظم
الاتحاد التونسي لشغل مظاهرات احتجاجيه
اليوم السبت وقال للمتحدث باسم الاتحادنا
الحكومه اغلقت ابواب المفاوضات والحوار من
جهتها اعلنت جبهه الخلاص المعارضه تمسك
بتنظيم احتجاجات يوم غد الاحد رغم رفض
السلطات الترخيصه لذلك
[موسيقى]
معنى من تونس مراسل الجزيره سيف الدين
بوعلاق سيف الدين اذا التحركات الشعبيه
بدات هذا الصباح في تونس
[تصفيق]
نعم حسن في الحقيقه الى حد هذه اللحظه
يتواصل توافذ المحتجين من مما لاحظته انه
لم يكون محتكرا فقط على النخبيب بل هناك
نشطاء من حساسيات سياسيه من المنظمات
المجتمع المدني من وسط مستقلين جميعهم
يتوافدون هنا بالقرب من المقر المركزي
للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل حيث سيكون
هناك خطاب للامين العام نور الدين التبوبي
ومن ثم ستكون هناك مسيره الى شارع الحبيب
بوركيبه رسميا لم تنطرق بعض التحرك ولكن
قد يكون خلال الدقائق المقبله هذا التحرك
حسن هو تتويج لسلسله تحركات الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل في اكثر من محافظه التونسيه
وحتى اليوم سيكون هناك تحرك كبير هنا في
العاصمه وفي الشارع الحبيب بورقيبه وستكون
ايضا هناك سلسله تحركات اخرى
عدد من المحافظات في بقيه محافظات البلاد
لماذا هذا التحرك حسن لعده اسباب وعده
تراكمات وايضا خلافات وتصدعات مع السلطه
الممثله في الرئيس قيس سعيد اولا ومنذ
اعلان اجراءات الاستثنائيه للحمص والعشرين
من يوليو سنه 2021 الان قرابه العامين
الرئيس او الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
دعاء الرئيس الى صيغه التشاركيه وحوار
وطني شامل يضم مختلف مكونات الطبقه
السياسيه والمدنيه هذا لم يحدث تقريبا حسن
ايضا كان هناك دعوه للتساور حول خريطه
الطريق رفض الرئيس قيس سعيد ايضا
المبادره باجراء او وضع خريطه الطريق
وانما وضع روزنامه خاصه به لاجراء استفتاء
الكتروني ومن ثم استفتاء شعبي على الدستور
ومن ثم انتخابات تشريعيه
مبكره كانت بدورين كانت نسبه المشاركه
فيها ضعيفه جدا وضعفه الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل بانها
لانها انتخابات دون الطعم ودون رائحه مثل
ما تسمع بجانب سوف تمر هذا تحرك جديد لعدد
من النقابيين هؤلاء ياتون مثلا من الجامعه
العامه للنقل وهي من اكبر النقابات في
العاصمه مثلما تلاحظ يتوافذ العشرات
شيئا فشيئا الى مقر المظاهره التحرك
المعلن امام مقر المركزي للاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل وفي مواصله لسلسله الخلافات
التي حضرت بين الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل وبين
السلطات التونسيه والتحديدا رئيس
الجمهوريه بصفته الان ووفق الدستور
والسلطه التنفيذيه الاولى في البلاد وايضا
هو من يدير بشكل كامل السلطه التنفيذيه
وايضا الحكومه كان هناك خلاف جدري اخر حول
المساله الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه واداره ملف التفاوض مع صندوق
النقد الدولي الاتحاد العام التونسي
الطلبه اولا بالشفافيه وتوضيح موقف
الحكومه وماذا ستقدم الحكومه التونسيه
لصندوق النقد الدولي حتى تتحصل مقابل قرض
بمبلغ 1.9 مليار دولار الاتحاد له عدد من
الخطوط الحمراء لا لتجميد الاجور لا لوقف
الانتدابات في القطاع العام ولا ايضا لرفع
الدعم عن المواد الاساسيه الى حد الان
الحكومه التونسيه لم تقدم تصورا واضحا لم
تعلن ما هي الاصلاحات التي ستقوم بها
للتحصل على هذا القرض والاتحاد يدعو بشكل
واضح الى مصالحه الشعب التونسي وتقديم
الورقات التفاوض التي قدمت لصندوق النقد
الدولي وايضا الى حد الان بالمجانسه هذا
الاتفاق معلق او لم يتم التوصل الى حل او
اتفاق نهائي مع صندوق النقد الدولي وما
زاد في حاله الاحتقان هو القاء القبض على
او ايقاف عدد من النقابيين على خلفيه نشاط
نقابي حسن نعم ايضا نقطه زادت من من حده
هذا الحراك الذي سنتابعه معك سيف الدين
بوعلاق اولا
باول خصوصا عندما يبدا بشكل رسمي شكرا
جزيلا لك مراسل الجزيره سيف الدين بوعلاق
من تونس